foreign
[Music]
what's your favorite morphe game I'd
have to think about that there's there's
quite a few good ones
okay we'll play a couple with him and
then I'll read more on
morphe's adventures in Europe
yeah I actually think the the fame of
the Opera game is one of the greatest
mysteries in chess like why are people
so obsessed with it
I don't I think it's because maybe of
the circumstances of the game make
people interested in it but the game
itself is extremely unremarkable
well if I had to think about what my
morphe number is probably not as much as
you think so
so who beat morphe I guess Anderson
you'd have to probably go through
steinettes and then Lasker
and my guess is last girl already like
lost to someone
um who lost to someone who whom I played
I'm sure
uh bavanick I don't think played
Emmanuel Oscar
thank you
yeah morphe is a super interesting
character
super interesting character
oh my gosh did I just wonder my queen
no
I have this move
I am not ghost fan back
I'm American
I should have gone I should have gone to
the other Rook
shoot
that was a very imprecise execution by
me
let's go here
it's okay
I'm still a piece up
I just have to be very careful
well doesn't being born in a country
make you
I mean I don't understand don't people
realize there's a difference between
like your ethnic background and your
nationality
it's not the same thing
the Opera game is not overrated
I agree no it's a good game I I never
said it's a bad game or it shouldn't be
shown I just think it's it's often
called the best game of all time or the
most instructive game of all time which
I think is absolute BS like under
indisputable BS
there's like so many more instructive
games
I'm messing this up oh my gosh
I think I messed this up
ah
here
foreign
back in charge
that was a poor technique but I think
I've hunted him down more if he would be
proud of this one
King A4 he has to play but then even
Knight C3 wins yeah this is winning
I was very close to letting that one
slip because if he had my Knights are
hanging that did not look great
yeah I should have known that
it's embarrassing
we'll probably look this line up
as a chess coach the Opera game seems
important to me
I can see the point it's it's it's worth
showing and it's worth including in
books and stuff
I just think there's a whole untapped
like
TR you know the amount of classical
games that are just as instructive if
not more instructive
that don't make their way into a lot of
trust books is sort of a pet peeve of
mine when it comes to like
you know listing good games and stuff
hard for me to tell you off the top of
my head what are some underrated games
that people should know
but if I thought about it I could
generate some games
who's the strongest player you have
facing classical chess so I in terms of
highest rated
I faced Wesley when he was over 2 800.
kramnik and Fabby when he was exactly
2800.
yeah so that would be the highest rateds
so I drew Wesley beat Fabby I've said
before amazingly I'm one and a half out
of two against players over 2 800.
by Miracle because of Wesleyan Fabi
now Wesley was just a Berlin draw so
that doesn't really count
but it's it's just it's just because the
sample size is Tiny
yeah I'm busted here I think
unfortunately
this guy
definitely has my number
there's just something about his
playstyle that makes it so hard for me
to play quickly
I mean the Berlin draw is not something
you have to study you can just like
know it or not know it
I saw the video when you were talking
like Wesley so yeah I'm in that video is
pretty funny but
to be completely honest they played the
Berlin against Daniel and
I am regretting it because he is
terrible chess player
um
I have no idea how he's able to maintain
the speed in these situations
I've
um talked about the kramnik game and
I've written the chest.com or Nicole
about it
foreign
I'm just getting smashed here
hanging by a thread
maybe we're okay B1
it's worth playing
I was hoping you would pre-move honestly
foreign
move
what a freaking move
oh no no no no no I didn't mean to do
that oh no
no
I made the wrong move there
of course he found that
ah
do you
[Music]
unbelievable that was an easy easy flag
if I just didn't
if I just if I took any six maybe that
would have been better prolonged the
process
but I deserve to lose that extra Planet
like a complete idiot in the Tactical
sequence
I'm always finding like this
foreign
yeah Rook takes H3 without it he's
losing on the spot
but I somehow managed to let him promote
the second Pawn which is dumb
foreign
obviously playoff takes C6 here what the
hell is F6
I have to take C6 and E7 I've got a shot
here
so stupid
just meltdown I probably maybe would
have even won the game because it's hard
for him to get rid of both of my Pawns
okay now I'm blundering pieces
maybe Knight C7 now this is lost
ruined the whole momentum of these two
stupid games
well he went from a piece up to piece
down so that's gonna help
unless I screw this up which is likely
but
see if I can keep my composure this time
unforgivable mental lapse that last game
I'm still lost I think
but at least I have a chance
if he's basically able to turn on the
Jets whenever he wants like
see if I can keep him
Under Wraps
no I didn't mean to do that either Rook
before
but okay this I should be able to flag
him maybe
there's another stupid move to give him
the passers
stupid
looks like I managed to lose it
seriously
what's going on here
I know I did that I'm trying to flag him
here
foreign
Jesus get it together man oh my gosh
oh
oh my goodness
these two games are driving me crazy
so many mistakes okay now he's maybe
tilted hopefully
I'm gonna repeat the line
okay so he goes again at A5
I mean I gotta do what I gotta do in
that game
ugh
last two days I've had a bunch of these
like
crazy moments
trying to hold out
no but again I'm repeating this line
where somehow I allow the trade of
Bishops and it's hard to break through
the bind I need to look this up
man
see if I can get another win here while
he's frustrated
I gave him so many chances that game
but somehow I was able to just keep
enough pieces on the board
okay moving on
all's well that ends well
let's try this very interesting move
before
yeah I can get out of anything when I
put my mind to it which is what
frustrating about the game that I lost
the fact that I
I literally got it so close and then
made one stupid decision
but that's Blitz
that's just what it is
uh
it's my position as interest so this is
okay Bishop E3 maybe I'm still gonna do
the morphe thing
but after I finish this match
chess is so brutal
you literally do so much to win a game
and then you make one little dumb move
and that's all it takes
I don't know how I won the last game
given that I was down a full piece and a
pawn for no comp he also ended up
blundering two pieces in in a row
somehow I'm getting getting my pieces
out here out of the gates
okay my headphones are
dying
both of you are tilted as cell I mean
I don't believe I am but I guess you
know better
I haven't lost two games in a row in
like five days so I think I'm able to
keep myself together
I was a little tilted first half of that
last game but
I did just enough to to keep myself in
it
why do mods keep deleting questions
about the speedrun well because
I've asked many many times at this point
for people to respect like my wishes
during the Stream
and the answer to will there be a Speed
Run game is always the same which is
that I never know until it happens
like I if I feel like it at the end I do
one if not I don't which is why I always
request that people don't watch the
stream if the only thing that you find
enjoyable in my content is the speedrun
which is fine you're not telling you
what you're allowed to find enjoyable or
not but
I would advise you that it would be a
frustrating experience to watch the
Stream
if the only reason you're watching it is
because you're hoping for a speed run
this is really pretty by the way
look at this oh look at this Rook a
seven rookie one mate there we go now
we're cooking
it's freaking right eat it you like some
of that
you want some more of that huh
all right let's play B5 this time just
keep winning keep winning keep winning
I hope that's reasonable by the way it's
not it's nothing personal
or like oh you know you said something
toxic
but it can definitely get really really
incessant when people are are spamming
it
yeah but he was already lost he was not
an exchange and I don't think there was
much he could have done there
he is very strong he drives me crazy
this guy he's
he always finds a way to get to me in
the end
so he's gonna win a couple games but if
I can avoid tilting I I'll be good
bye bye speedrun bye bye
the streamers play gentian for for
stream stream Bounty I mean the problem
convention
from Tiana
Alaskan class again with Dion what makes
Daniel a good Blitz player you know but
when classical chess and Dion Daniel
would never win that game that's why I'm
saying classical chess and Diana Daniels
struggle
all right
um
let's try F5
just
Tanya broke his speedrun
okay this looks like a pretty decent
position actually
nothing better than that
looking at night before
foreign
there's some beautiful lines there but
none of it works of course
okay I need a move
this this is always what he does
makes me think in critical moments how
dare you how dare you
force yourself to trust my intuition
hey don't install my dark skirt Bishop
this is the key this is the key to my
position
you want to be toxic and banned you
won't be toxic and banned you can toxic
and Beyond
do you want to be taxing a band I can
ban you I mean if that's drawing and
talking about it you can get banned
right you want to get beyond all right
let's go G6
all right here's a band [__] you
wanna be toxic Advantage Jasper to
Daniel
that's fun okay this is a fun position
but this is why I love the night Earth
this is why I love the night or if this
position right here is why I freaking
love the night Earth
okay but let's actually win the game and
then I can
start talking
okay
oh okay I see
good thing good thing I said no
wow Avenger that's too complicated for
me to understand
wait who is insane
more Bush League from Diana
playing typical garbage tricks and
Knight Earth I mean I mean I hope from
Dan beating me it's more it's more the
way that it beats me and you know it's
more garbage tricks he knows or garbage
spank spank this loser
um
have you played Emery Tate no well Emery
has passed away
um but no I never played Emery today
thank you
when you became a GM 18
Okay so we've righted the ship after
that disaster of a game that I lost
it really is a very funny clip no that
is one of the funniest things ever in
the Chess World
yeah no religion
no politics what do they say I've waited
at The Family Table
yeah religion and politics I think are
the two things you avoid on a twitch
stream
how many times have I played Gary zero
zero and OTB
that's an underrated clip the Hans why
is he so smart but yeah that that one is
hilarious
that one is honestly very very very very
funny
talks a good band
you wanna be toxic bands all right let's
go here how many times do many many many
many
there are certain videos and I think
everybody has those videos that you just
come back to from time to time
you just watch them on a like cycle
and like every once in a while
you know you need to re-watch it because
it's so good
yeah this guy of frustration inducing
for sure but I've got a nice bind on the
position as a lot when I'm up on time in
the late middle game against him I
usually win
the problems usually start if I enter
time pressure because he's so good at
generating problems I'm pressure
I don't know
all right
spicy but shackle like congratulating me
for beating Carlson especially
this game is over Red Rover population
Danny wrench
oh I found something sexy
Bishop takes D5 Knight d8 and he has he
has to give up his Queen this is a funny
Construction
foreign
[Music]
yes
this is a very good Sicilian for black
and okay
foreign
have I ever played a match versus Hans
yeah many many of course I have
hey Cara said you're better than him at
everything yeah exactly
kramnik does have a pretty high view of
himself that is true
can't argue with that
but
um he has a good reason to
oh God what are my views on Hans I
thought we were over that
that's old that's old uh old news I
can't muster up the energy to talk about
that anymore it is what it is it's over
now
we'll see
we'll see I mean we'll see how
how Hans does
you know
you just wait and see
huh
well I would like to not get sued yes
but I am
promised Hans at the start that I would
give a fair objective evaluation of the
situation and I think I was able to do
that
without
unsubstantiated opinions
here
that I mean how do you feel like you
don't know that
you don't know that Hans is not going to
be invited anywhere and Magnus controls
everything that's totally not it's a
it's not necessarily true I mean a lot
of organizers might take Hans aside
in fact the court of public opinion I
think really does believe that Magnus
did not act appropriately
um vis-a-vis his withdrawal so
Magnus just might have to suck it up and
play Hans
because the one thing that to me is Inc
is is is without I mean I could bet you
know Silver Dollar on is that Hans did
not cheat in the singfield Cup game
and we get a peaceful resolution well
that's always what I what I want
I think a peaceful resolution would be
possible
because the positives that came of this
is that the anti-cheating measures are
taken more seriously now and that's a
good thing
now would Magnus and Hans ever like
shake hands and
you know let bygones be bygones
well that would probably require Magnus
to make a public statement that he
withdraws his accusations of cheating
from like the singfield cup
I don't think we're gonna see something
like that
what was your favorite part of living in
the Bay Area probably the food
and the people I don't know Kavita
people eh
foreign
podcast yes I'm just going to arrive at
his house and that's that's how you get
enough podcasts as big as Lex Friedman
while I'm at it I'm gonna I'm gonna make
a tour of the podcast like freedom and
Joe Rogan I'm just gonna I'm just gonna
arrive at their studio and
that's how it works
yep
hmm
you know the requests that they get per
day yeah it's crazy that's why when I
sent that message
I don't think it's going to land even in
the right pile
maybe I should maybe I'll go on the Alex
Jones podcast while I'm at it
so did you know that not a not a single
one of the world championship matches
actually happened in fact aliens Wilhelm
Stein is actually an alien
and he is the UFO
that infiltrated the Earth and decided
to play chess okay um let's go here
what's that ass
erted cower of residing yeah Target car
is definitely suspicious
phones are dying
foreign
yeah I honestly
Lex Friedman is super popular these days
it's it's I was discussing this with
someone I I can't
honestly I find it very very difficult
to get there like I I would go on his
podcasts
um but I find it difficult to actually
get through an entire episode
like I don't know what it is
but I I just
find it hard to like
maybe it's his voice but I I don't know
what it is exactly but it's
I don't know it's hard the guests are
really interesting
but it's difficult for me to actually
listen to an entire podcast
don't you get annoyed by Russians
practically begging you nobody's begging
me to be Russian
and the people who do that are mostly
not Russians
and in fact when I stream in Russian is
mostly
non-russians who are trolling and
getting offended that I'm not doing his
dream in English
I don't know it's the voice I also
struggle to get through most podcasts
that's true
yes I have listened
to the Sam Harris podcast but also same
issue like I don't think I've gotten
through a complete episode
but there's I've there are some ones I
liked
yeah they are
these bowring
you're just salting he didn't invite you
all right let's go here
[__]
I am busted here let's see if I can
Swindle him
problem is this move is pretty but it
doesn't create a threat
we know figures gay here
you're gonna take rusky
I don't mind our rooskies
okay I got a flag his ass
with a bullet bus who the bullet bus now
you're my territory boy now you're my
territory boy
are you gonna win that pawn huh how
about that
some of that that's right
there's more where that came from that's
right exactly
I'm pretty sure I use it sparingly don't
I
I mean I think it's a pretty very pretty
accent
can you use the southern accent next to
commentated tournament
I don't know about that
for the entirety of the commentary yes
that's the best way for me to like
Drive every single person crazy
yeah I should do it in like a complete
deadpan like as if as if nothing's the
matter and didn't deny yeah deny that I
ever sounded differently like what's the
big like why are you
what's the matter like
what was sounded like this
total gaslighting yeah
okay I'm kind of getting crushed here
out of the opening
okay I'm just gonna get out of there
well look at this position and I'm
got like no pieces developed that's the
problem
yeah like the Hans accent that's crazy
Bishop takes A6
yeah she finds this move
yep it's over
that was a terrible game unfortunately
terrible game
I just didn't get my pieces out
unfortunately
okay can I find a Swindle here
let's start with the check
I'm trying to Swindle him
yeah I do love Accents in general I just
think
hmm
he spots tactics so fast it's actually
pretty wild
dude I might have just spotted the
craziest Perpetual check of all time I
think I might have just spotted an
insane Perpetual if I calculated this
correctly
oh my gosh look at this pattern King you
won Queen G1
Queen F1 Queen E3 he's I'm two pieces
down but it's perpet
oh that's that's cool
yeah that's nice Queen F1 Queen E3
that's actually pretty hard to believe
all right last one with him
and we'll just read about morphe
that is very satisfying but okay
remote classic triple stack right
triangle road to juice juicer thank you
thank you Gretzky meerkat something so
much thanks so much thank you so much
Persian for the sub thank you so much
why am I playing C3
definitely Fisher
and unfortunately Fisher turned nasty
when he
you know when his his issues came up to
the surface
morphe not so much
hmm
are you trolling I Slaughter poppies or
do you have evidence of that
foreign
God this guy so fast free movie he's
like yeah no I calculated this and I
want to let you know that I calculated
that
what's up Hannah
Newt Fisher totally was crazy
it's like
Fisher didn't have like massive mental
issues is just
totally I mean off the wall
and they were manifested for like
decades even before he started saying
like super nasty stuff in the 2000s
I mean even in the 70s it was you know
clear that he was I mean even with his
demands in of tournaments and fear that
his food was poison and stuff like it
was obvious that
he was moving in kind of the wrong
direction
that's a nice take so it's way
yep
I mean obviously he could act normally
and in the 70s
he like if you watch talk shows with him
and stuff like he's he sounds totally
normal but that
you know would be simplistic to say that
like oh
you know these these issues like
manifested themselves gradually
okay there's absolutely no need to give
up this point it was stupid doesn't take
it
bye bye Danya bye bye
genius is close to Madness
okay
I don't think he's them I mean this is
our usual score
I think yet Bishop takes F7 in the game
in the opening let's see
where
oh you're absolutely right I did a
bishop F7
TM girl
damn girl
this idea
now it's not it's not that clear because
he might trap my knight but it appears
that he doesn't trap it easily because
I'm defending B7
oh my gosh there was a very famous game
uh Judith polgargin's Boris spaski they
played a match
um a classical match and Polgar so they
went down one of the main lines of the
Roy Lopez
so they were playing uh the sides of
variation and spaski
in this position
um let me remember how this went
how did people under this oh yeah
um there they're there
how did they get this trick because
Polgar accidentally
um
didn't oh Knight B8 yeah Knight B8 this
is the Briar variation
which is very popular and in this
position the move is Bishop B7
but spassky played rookie a on accident
and Polgar instantly played Knight F1
which is the main lot which is basically
or like Bishop C2 or whatever missing
Bishop takes up seven check one zero
because just it's so rare for like a top
player to miss something like this and
both players just assume that they were
following Theory
it's honestly it was a crazy moment
there have been some moments like this
where like an opening mix-up was ignored
by both players
it is a cool attack I really like and of
course there's the very famous Fisher
roshevsky game from the US championship
years ago
speaking of Fisher where roshevsky let's
see if I can remember it from memory
remember it from memory that makes a lot
of sense
I no I think rashevsky played G6
all right let me look it up I don't
remember exactly the move order
remember from memory no let me look up
the game
it was like Knight F6 here I think
so like roshevsky basically tried a
weird Sicilian and he just got burned
instantly
it's a pretty uh pretty well-known game
yeah there it is so it was an
accelerated dragon
it was an accelerated Dragon main line
and roshevsky played
castles Bishop B3
Knight A5 so the main move here even
today is A5
but roshevsky tries this new move Knight
A5
and Fisher just eats him alive 1958 New
York E5
I wonder how many of you know this game
and here out of a completely clear blue
sky Bishop takes F7 check is winning
beautiful tactic because the queen is
undefended and the Queens are x-raying
each other so this traps the queen
and you can't take well roshovsky did
end up taking but he lost the queen and
if King takes F7 you still go Knight E6
again d e Queen takes d8 is winning
and if King takes E6 there's like
obvious Checkmate there's made in five
with G4 Rook G1
and now
anticlimactic but okay just like Queen
E4 and queen G4 or queen back to G2 with
too many mate threads
yeah that is it is honestly crazy how
these tactics can occur out of
absolutely nowhere Bishop takes F7
tactics in general are extremely
widespread in a lot of different
openings
so
it's always worth uh paying attention
to those types of tactics I had a game I
remember
that was super satisfying and it was
satisfying because my opponent in this
game was an old Russian dude who had
beaten me at our chess club
in San Francisco like a thousand times
and I finally beat him
Yeah so basically in this position this
is obviously a Roy Lopez at this point I
already cooked up a tactic
so I played Bishop B3 and I was like
please move your d-pawn
please move your Jeep on and he
instantly plays D4
and obviously Bishop takes F7 check
again and this is very easy I mean he
won King h8 and give up the exchange but
this is already a game over because if
he goes
King G7 then there's 96 check and wins
the queen king G8 Queen B3
and Knight F7 wins the queen as well so
anyways
um worth uh worthwhile tactic all right
I'll be right back then I'll I'll finish
off the morphe thread and then we'll
maybe play a couple more games and call
it a night
Max laying on morphe
here's what he said to continue what I
started earlier
um so this is in 1860.
but morphe plays five games
simultaneously against some of the most
expert players including the well-known
French player M de riviere the tables
are arranged in a row each table being
occupied on the one side by a player and
then the other passage was left free
along which the single antagonist that
is morphe might pass backwards and
forwards
with regards to this exciting feat a
contemporary remarks
Mr morphy seems to play perfectly at
ease generally making his moves with
great rapidity although sometimes
stopping and seeming to give the move
and hand a good deal of careful
consideration we Endeavor to ascertain
whether like other great players he had
any favorite move or leading idea in his
play
and there did seem to be a little
uniformity in the cases in which he
obtained the first move so he played
both white and black
okay this is a meaningless phrase so
clearly this person is not a chess
player but as this happened only in two
cases out of the five he was in the
other three necessarily influenced by
the opening of his opponent
speaking generally his style of play
seems to be rapid and impetuous and is
um
some French phrase that I know so
perfect that he can Master at one glance
all the exigencies of the board
more than once in the course of play his
opponents had to call for time
which he conceded with the most good
humored courtesy so that basically means
an assimil when you arrive at the board
your opponent is supposed to make him
make his move
um and but people have a certain amount
of passes like you can take another pass
through to think so that's what that
means
which you conceded with the most good
humored courtesy chatting in the interim
carelessly with whoever chance to stand
near him
the ultimate Flex
the great secret of his success
as a chess player would appear to lie in
the wonderful power and tenacity of his
memory
he plays the most abstruse and
reflective of known games
the only Advantage he has is The
Prestige of his wonderful name blah blah
blah which certainly had considerable
effect in producing caution on the part
of his opponent so people were obviously
scared of him
The Games took place in the elegant and
capacious smoking room of the Saint
James restaurant and all the players to
whom Mr morphy was opposed to worshiped
the genius
worshiped his genius
we observed whoever that he did not
smoke an important fact for the modern
Advocates of the counterblast
interesting
Mr morphe although an American would
appear to deny himself his cigar
in order to secure the necessary amount
of cerebral acidity
so morphe was playing derivier Bowden
of bowden's mate Barnes it was one of
the top English player lowenthal and
bird so he was playing five of the top
European players simultaneously
the play commenced at six o'clock
p.m and was kept up with great spirit
till the late hour of the night the
following was the result
the game at the first board Was Won by
morphe
second game was a draw third one by
Barnes
fourth by morphe Fifth a draw so he
didn't do amazing we give below four out
of the five games played on this
occasion the game with Mr Barnes not
having come to our knowledge of course
somehow conveniently the one morphe lost
was not available
yeah long games
a few days after the Simon morphe left
England on board the Persia
interesting
very interesting
wow look at this and he didn't just play
an over the board symbol
so he played a match with a French
player named mongregion who he crushed
then he returns to England
and he arrives at the London chess club
we hail the arrival of this
extraordinary genius
or a keen and just appreciation of his
abilities blah blah blah will Dallas
making Epoch still more glorious
remarkable Mr morphe arrives in town
last Saturday and on the next Tuesday
visited St James's Hall where a host of
noted chess players were assembled to
welcome him amongst their circles on the
following day he went to the London
chess club where for the third time
since he arrived in Europe he exhibited
the wonderful feat of playing eight
blindfold games simultaneously against
the strongest players of the club
out of which he won two the remaining
six were given up as drawn on account of
the lateness of the hour okay all right
or maybe he forgot the positions which
is I think more likely this astonishing
performance commenced at 5 pm and lasted
till after midnight
seven hours of blindfold okay that is
crazy
on the following day at dinner was given
in honor of our hero by the London chess
club
all the top players were present
wow
that's pretty crazy
so before he came to England
he was in France
wow called out so he crushes this guy
mongratian and it wasn't even close
the brilliant career of a distinguished
Countryman was for Paul morphe whose
services to the game of chess can hardly
be overestimated
and then he was in Germany before he
went to France
wow
the challenge of the veteran English
Champion Staunton by the young American
has given occasion a well-known and
greatly extended controversy in the
course of which both parties often went
too far
the blameable point of the englishman's
conduct is one of precision in his
declarations and in keeping up with his
well-known pretensions
Stanton is a man of Honor cannot be
wholly excused as he has not behaved
generously but a bad intention can by no
means be proved against him nor anything
which may be considered so this was the
drama of the day
this was the the Hans Neiman Affair of
the 1850s is why Stanton was not playing
morphe
it may however be taken as a real fact
that public opinion has judged his
strength to be decidedly inferior to
that of the American
so everybody knew what was going on
interesting
Mr morphy hopes before returning to this
country to have the pleasure of
contending against Mr Max Lange
and he's giving odds of Pawn and move to
everybody so they he would give them the
odds he would essentially start the game
without a pawn and they would have the
first move
so let's see
wow his schedule in Europe was crazy
it's not too simultaneous blindfold
games he was in Mexico
playing a match with lowenthal who was
one of the top European players in
crushing him
yeah pretty interesting
yeah so here Max Lang talks about morphe
Style
okay so morphe was a genius
a few words under that of memory Mr
morphe seems to forget nothing from the
game which he himself played yesterday
to that which he read in the chess
Chronicle a year ago
playing blindfolded out the side of a
board
yeah
inventive power power of analysis
style of play singularly Fearless more
so we must confess than any of which we
have yet seen a post to it he is ready
to accept any of the most critical
gambits
yeah
interesting
I'll read more about this I'll read I'll
read more of this book later and maybe
share some interesting passages
foolish invention of the daily paper so
this was published in the newspapers
morphe and staunton's uh back and forth
yeah
very interesting
morphe was also of course playing Adolf
Anderson
who was uh the top German player of the
day and basically crushed him in every
match
anyways
um
back to the chest
it's John let's play until maybe three a
couple more games
what book is this this is by Max Lange
from 1860. so this was written during
morphy's life
it's a morphe's biography and annotated
games
match with Anderson
wow extensive annotations
but I was really interested to see how
people perceived him during his life
like did people realize that he was the
greatest player of all time
or greatest player of his day and the
answer is yes
like it was even though there was no
there were no ratings
everybody knew that he was basically you
know in a league of his own
so it's not the case a lot of people
seem to claim that you know
these players are only appreciated after
they died but that was not true in
morphy's case
he was idolized by
everybody across the world
so when morphy came to Europe
Adolf Anderson was considered the top
player because Stanton was retired
because stanzan was retired
um
wow so Anderson was so excited to face
morphe
that he came to Paris to meet him and
prepared for every Earth but his
championship in well-earned Laurel Crown
into the scales
played for no money
Anderson
first first to seven would be the Victor
the whole of the match consisting of 11
games some of which were very obstinence
and contested lasted a week
morphe 7 Anderson 2 and 2 drawn games
not even close
the Americans tried a new attack in the
Rue Lopez opening which variation though
introduced into practice by German
players is comparatively little known
and this very game was won by the
American champion through an evident
mistake of his opponent
because the king's gambo was obviously
the you know main opening of the day
an American Master exhibitor's perfect
knowledge of the Sicilian opening
playing against the so-called French
opening
yeah
so he definitely analyzed openings and
stuff a lot more carefully than his
contemporaries
yeah wow tons of annotated games
so then he played with the French
players
Bill Stein is dark morph because he knew
what would happen bill steinits
bill
here we go with this again
morphe played another eight board
blindfold simul the sitting lasted 10
hours
these two players are the first to
surrender at nine o'clock was a drawn
game and rejoice at its acceptance
when the Clock Struck 10 the last
opponents surrendered thereupon followed
a thunder of Applause which continued so
long
that morphe was in literal sense stunned
by it
eight game blindfold simul and he wins
seven of them
not too bad
and Littles in the present in the
English translation characterized his
feat of playing eight opponents at once
blindfold is the most wonderful thing he
had ever seen
Mr morphe expressed his deep sense of
gratitude
blah blah blah
Mr morphy not only played
eight games in his head but he also
played them in a masterly style which is
evident by his victories of her strong
players
besides his combinations of either
soundness and depth produce General
astonishment and the performance made
upon those president impression of the
miraculous and incredible in Aid board's
Aid board blindfold Simon was still very
impressive Magnus did ten boards but I
would not be able to do more than three
is already like pushing it
so
eight boards blindfold is crazy
with with like good players
he sat at one end of the room and had
eight tables at the other were his
opponents
the eyes of our hero were directed
toward the window opposite him his arm
carelessly thrown over a chair
and thus he gave move after move
following the numbers of the boards as
it's still done now
we cannot attach any way to the
assertion made by some correspondents on
acquainted with chess the blindfold
player corrected some false moves which
were reported to him
in the consequence of an accidental
disarrangement of the pieces
as this would prove a great weakness on
the part of his adversaries
so yeah no obviously
the moves would have to be communicated
correctly to him
yeah the blindfold sign was the most
impressive thing to most people not his
actual matches
oh here we go this again young Bobby
Fischer so morphe arrives in England and
the President says
he hopes that morphe would come off
victorious in all his encounters but one
and that he hoped the veteran English
player stunton would be the counter but
the match with Sandra will not take
place
for the English Champion it appears had
not fully made up his mind to enter the
contest
nice
yeah a shame
the Umpire is Mr stunt and so morphe
before that plays low and thaw
in England lowenthal being top five in
the world
Staunton accepted the match
but as for an indefinite delay
in the meantime morphe played another
match
with lowenthal
and morphe crushes him the winner of the
first nine games was to Bear the stake
of 100 pounds
not bad
thus the analytical result of the match
points out the European player's
remarkable searches theoretical
knowledge of American the superior
practical player
yep
some more if he crushes lowenthal
long Voyage Mr morphy has played some
chess games in London
but probably has not recovered from his
fatigues of his voyage from America
morphe's long Voyage but I see a thing
to which he was totally unaccustomed
caused him to meet the strong players of
the clubs and devons of London at a
disadvantage jawag
but as soon as the effects of travel
passed away was himself again
interesting
overcome the long fatigues of a civil
wedge and the uncomfortable feelings of
First Impressions in a strange country
yeah
I didn't even know this book existed
so here they discuss what openings he
plays
this motor plays peculiarity morphe who
in close game systematically places the
bishop behind the center Pawn
strikes is however the extraordinary
opening close though it may be morphe
may have deviated from a sound unusual
practice blah blah
founded on deep study of modern chess
Works among which perhaps are
several books that morphe read
Mr Barnes one of the strongest members
of the Saint George chess club kept his
ground against morphe in the beginning
each having won four games when morphe
recovered the consciousness of his
superiority his confidence returned with
it I can beat that man and I shall beat
him he exclaimed and finally he won 19
games to his opponent seven
damn girl
in the Saint Jude's Club where his
reception was very cordial he was
reported to have expressed
his desire to play one of the strong
English players a match for stakes from
100 pounds to a thousand pounds
according to his opponent's Wishes the
next day he visited the newly opened
philidor chess room
and rejoice those present by his
Splendor Splendid specimen of blindfold
play
no this is a mistake oh sorry this is a
report from the newspaper but Max Lang
says this is a mistake morphe did not
play blindfold in the Philadelphia chest
room but took part in a game of four
playing with muklao against Brian and
falkbeer who developed the Falk beer
Gambit it's funny that all these like
people after whom the openings were
named was just were just like plea
people
the game resulted in basically hand and
brain or alternate moves I think
on the 8th of June in the morning morphe
made his appearance in New York in order
to Embark next day in the steamer Arabia
for the old world
let's see how long it took him on
Wednesday the 23rd okay not that long 15
days
it wasn't that crazy
a voyage across the ocean in the
interest of Chess was something so new
and romantic that external impediments
insensibly disappeared before so
enchanting a prospect
interesting
oh here we go with this again
morphy goes after Stanton okay this is
funny
October 6th sir on my arrival in England
three months ago I renewed The Challenge
to you personally which the New Orleans
chess club had given to you previously
you immediately accepted but demanded a
month's delay in order to prepare
yourself for the match
okay
subsequently you proposed that the time
should be postponed until after the
Birmingham tournament to which I agreed
on the approach of the period you had
fixed I addressed you a communication
request that the necessary preliminaries
might be settled but you left London
without replying to it
I went to Birmingham for the express
purpose of asking you to put a stop to
this delay by fixing a date for the
opening of our match but before the
opportunity presented itself you came to
me in the presence of Littleton the
president of the English chess club you
stated that your time was much occupied
in editing a new edition of Shakespeare
and that you were under a heavy bonds to
your publisher but you reiterated your
intention to play me and said that if I
would consent to further postpone until
the first week of November you would
within a few days communicate with me
the exact day I have not heard from you
further either privately by letter or
Through The Columns of the London chess
news
permit me to repeat what I have
invariably declared in every chess
community that I'm not a professional
chess player
that I never wish to make my skill I
possess the means of peculiar
advancement my Earnest which is never to
play for any state but honor
my friends in New Orleans however have
proposed a sum
sponsored that some have been has been
ready to for you
considerable time passed since my
arrival in Paris I've been assured by
numerous gentlemen that the value of
these Stakes can be immediately
increased to any amount so this match
would have been sponsored but for myself
personally reputation is the only
incentive I recognize
I have the honor to remain your humble
servant Paul morphy
Stanton replies
oh God sir in reply to your letter I
have to observe that you must be
perfectly conscious of the difficulty in
the way of my engaging in a chess match
is one over which I have no control
you were distinctly apprised in answer
to the extraordinary proposal of your
friends that I should leave my home my
family and my job and proceed to New
Orleans for the purpose of playing chess
with you
that a long and arduous contest even in
London would be an undertaking too
formidable for me to Embark without
ample opportunity for the recovery of my
old strength and play
together with such arrangements as it
would prevent the sacrifice of my
professional engagements
upon your unexpected arrival in Europe
the same thing was repeated to you in my
acceptance of your challenge was
entirely conditional on my being able to
gain time for practice
The Experience however of some weeks
during which I have labored unceasingly
to the serious injury of my health shows
that it is not only impossible
for me to save time for the purpose but
by no means short of giving up a great
work on which I am engaged
to be continued a match at Chester
Cricket may be a very good thing and
it's on its own but not nobody but a
Madman would forfeit his engagements and
imperil his professional reputations
okay yeah this is gets interesting
is that they um went after each other
like that
[Music]